so over the last couple of days we've
spent some time
going through the really shocking
revelations that are made in bob
woodward's new book rage including of
course that donald trump all the way
back in february knew the seriousness of
coronavirus downplayed it publicly
for political reasons even though he
clearly knew and now 200 000 people
nearly have died and
that is shocking it's not an
exaggeration to say that is a shock it
is shocking that anybody would do that
any human would do that
regardless of their motivations or their
position but
our friend and he is our friend he's
been on the show a couple of times steve
almond
wrote a really good commentary for wbur
which we are linking to uh you can also
check out
my interviews with steve allmand he
wrote a really good op-ed
where he makes the case that as
ridiculous as
as donald trump's actions are as
shocking and outrageous and immoral as
it is that donald trump
didn't just deceive about coronavirus i
mean he straight up lied knowingly lied
he didn't just get it wrong he lied
the real thing we should be horrified
about
is that it won't matter and
i actually agree with steve almond i've
given this a lot of thought over the
last 24 hours
and yes donald trump publicly
said the virus is under control we shut
it down it's going to go away like a
miracle 15 cases will soon be zero
all of it privately he knew how serious
it was
he believed that it was so contagious in
early february that it was spreading
through the air and he said it to bob
woodward
and it's insane but as steve allman
points out
the shock is that trump's support will
likely
not move as a result this story will
rage
for some period of time just like early
last week early this week late last week
rather
the troops are losers and suckers story
was raging
just like the ukraine story did just
like every story and then something else
will happen
and things will move on and donald
trump's approval
will keep bouncing between 39 and 47
and ultimately this election is going to
come down to
not the country realizes wow
this is bad hey we're a laughingstock
hey this is a
joke we have to stop this this election
in the end
is going to come down to can our turnout
outdo their voter suppression
that is ultimately what this will be
about and if you want any proof of this
simply spend some time checking out the
posts
over the last 48 hours in the typical
pro trump
on enclaves of the internet and what you
will find is that over the last 48 hours
as the story exploded first of all for
the most part
the trumpists just ignored it they
pretend the story doesn't exist
and then when it does come up they
either say
it's fake news or they assail someone's
character
like bob woodward in this case they will
protect
trump at all costs the less involved
ones
will simply experience cognitive
dissonance and say it can't possibly be
real
and almost every day it seems certainly
every week
there is a bombshell that would end
other presidencies it would they would
have ended other presidencies and i said
this yesterday and i think it bears
repeating
if the world really made sense trump
never would have been elected wouldn't
be possible the public wouldn't be so
stupid as to do
it but it happened if the world made a
little more sense than it does
trump would have had to resign by now
but instead trump has
a shot at four more years he really does
and the republican party including mitch
mcconnell
and friends mcconnell and friends mitch
and friends allowed this to happen
they could have intervened they could
have removed trump they could have voted
to convict on impeachment
they could have done any number of
things but they are also complicit and
they need to be punished as well
and hopefully some of them will be
punished by losing
martha mcsally for one and others but
later their punishment should come as
well i keep thinking back
to that speaker that woman at the dnc
who spoke
about her father who died of coronavirus
who
believed trump that um it wasn't
really serious and she said you know
it's kind of a cliche line but it but it
is powerful in a sense as well she said
her father's
only pre-existing condition before he
died before he caught coronavirus
was that he trusted donald trump and
meanwhile
donald trump has run counter-propaganda
we talked yesterday how now donald trump
has been nominated by some far-right
norwegian politician
for a nobel peace prize if you can
imagine something more outrageous
and he's been retweeting that and
running a counter narrative
for a second step back come with me on
this thought experiment step back
imagine the worst thing trump could
possibly do okay what
and and what could it be and then how
would his base react
and you will realize that this bob
woodward fiasco
is unlikely to have a huge impact
imagine an audio tape of trump trump
screaming the n-word
imagine a video of him with putin
talking about a quid pro quo to win the
election imagine a video of trump
committing sexual assault or trump's
taxes come out and it turns out yeah
he's cheating on his taxes
i still don't think it would matter to a
large portion of his base
maybe maybe if trump was on video saying
the people who voted me they're suckers
and idiots
i wouldn't be caught dead with them i
don't even like them at my clubs
maybe that would make an impact and i'm
not even sure i think even in that case
if trump just straight up insulted his
followers
which he's done indirectly but if he did
it more directly
i think most of them still say you know
i don't need trump to like me
i just need him to make america great
and by the way i'm sure he was talking
about somebody else not me specifically
uh he wasn't talking about followers
like me he was talking about supporters
like some other people
even in that case i struggle to see
how it really affects donald trump's
approval so
check out steve allman's piece on wbur
we're linking to it uh about this
i think steve is right i think the real
tragedy
is that this isn't going to hurt trump
in any kind of substantive way
if you love feeding your intellectual
curiosity but you're always
struggling to find the time check out
one of my
all-time favorite apps called blinkist
blinkist lets you consume an entire book
on your way home from work
they take thousands of popular
nonfiction books condense each one
into text or audio that you can get
through in just 15 minutes and you get
all of the important
core ideas and information from that
book it's perfect
if you don't have enough time to do all
the reading you want to do
or if you just want to sample a book
before you buy the entire thing
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great stephen hawking
this is a book that i have been aware of
for so long and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic to check it out on blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about
eight bucks a month and you get the
entire library
but you can try it totally free and get
25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
pacman i've put the link right
underneath this video